hello and welcome to la vie James Watts
weekly hanging every tuesday at two p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com I'm
not sick anymore at least that's what
Scott Butterworth and Peter Brandt hope
as they sit with me for the next well
for the next time yeah I just realized
you're not on for the whole show I think
you are I am susceptible to getting ill
okay we are already breathing the same
air though so where's it's it's you that
we're sick now or not so at this point
mall in I made out with these
microphones before we went live I'd
totally believe sure yeah great show
last week congratulations yeah I rebuke
Chris waters yes and entice enticed I is
already wearing his denim shorts and
black lighting plastic balls it's real
hot in Austin how did you know that very
hot in Texas right now yeah he's already
having to use cabs cuz there's no eber
nope and he's waiting for sat by
Southwest and the Grand Prix and that's
everything i know about austin that
covers it yeah BBQ and Formula One and
yeah chris is thinking up ideas to get
us to buy watch dogs too probably yes
yeah attacking the planet maybe the crew
to ya gonna hike a banach god it was it
was an xbox the game gold games with
gold game and apparently it was download
a bunch of times we had a new story
about this one the crew it's like oh
really pretty well when it was free i
can kind of see that cuz it's like it's
like the evolved thing right where if
enough people are like mary was talking
yesterday about how that's that's free
to play in air right and she was playing
a bunch of anything evolved is yeah I
think so I'm like now they're getting
like the the mass amount of people to
play it again I can kind of see the same
with the crew or like if your buddies
were playing yeah and you join I was not
too clearly enough people were
interested like I'll try it sure and
you're right it's the kind of game that
benefits for more players so it actually
makes a lot of sense that was a good
call to like get it into that program
it's a fun game I think the crews all
right get off it's fine it's very fine
yes who reviewed it the original I did
and ok and I did wild run oh right ok
which was still fine it was better they
improved even like the core driving and
it added some really fun stuff like
monster trucks yeah motorcycle right you
know I'll be honest guys I was not
expecting to talk about the crudités
yeah we're seeing a media
we diverted from the game plans the
Chris waters is already exceeding doing
a that you be blog inception is real he
planted the seed on today show no we
watch of cool stuff to talk about bets
talk to Scott about their sex mankind
divided yeah you played a bunch of yes I
talk about Pokemon go and the current
title of the segment is Pokemon go
weekly [ __ ] up story roundup I'm sure
we'll changed out for the break ash I'm
pretty sure that's too late now we're
gonna talk to Peter bash I am setsuna
yeah we're gonna have an accident talk
about that as well she played it too
she's not here she is ill yo ill almost
like somebody made out with her
microphone it was she on the show last
week cuz I would explain it no no
microphone okay well there you go
independently sick then and Jimmy thanks
coming in to talk about graphics cards
thanks to 1060 which is a cheaper
version of the 10 17 1080i imagine yes
we'll see if that's any good right but
first of all let's talk about Adam
Jensen shall we yeah Deus Ex mankind
divided recently supposed to come out
februari of this year i believe so now
it's coming out oddest 23rd five years
to the day yeah since the deus ex human
revolution I can't believe that's been
five years yeah that seems that's
troubling yeah I agree actually hadn't
even realized it had been that long that
crazy quite a long 2011 I'd cuz it
seemed like they were dead on to make a
sequel to this game it seemed to do well
yeah it's only surprised people people
were talking about it well past the
release date to like it was still a
relevant game a while allow yeah a lot
of people seem to enjoy the only
criticism of that one if I remember
correctly was the the sort of boss
fights for sued not to be stealthy and
forced you to play a certain way that
was the longest game was about player
agency and it sort through it at the
window that was that's exactly right
yeah so you've played a bunch of how
much have you played Scott yeah so I got
to play it back in September and then I
got to play it again last week and saw
it different sections both times so back
in September I sought a lot of like just
dedicated story missions that were
focused on combat or stealth it was just
like straight up gameplay so what I
played more recently was like the
open-world segments and a lot of the
social conversation system so I've now
seen actually a really well-rounded
portrait of the game which was really
nice the more recent stuff was like I
got to check out Prague which is sort of
the
home city it's sort of like Detroit was
in human Revolution you'll jump off from
there and go to other parts of the world
to do missions but that sort of seems to
be the hub area the main hub area so I
got to kind of like look around for side
quests and explore and find hidden stuff
like that so yeah new areas side quests
conversation system even saw some new
augment stuff like that cool I want to
keep this open to people the child as
well and at donia Dwyer in the game spot
shot at a twitch chat if you have any
questions and I'll be sure to pass them
on first of all I want to ask you about
Prague because I got a real like half
like to vibe off of the gameplay when I
see this cuz that was also like set in a
some sort of like generic we don't know
better Russia and maybe or Eastern
European city right yeah and what was it
like exploring Prague how big was the
open world like what were you kind of do
what was the moment-to-moment actions
you see like you ambling around and
talking to people or where you're like
using your stealth and stuff like that
like how did I actually feel yeah so
during those sections you're free to
explore your own pace like you you there
are no like time restrictions really
there are no directives you can kind of
just like take your time between
missions and explore and do whatever you
want to be clear it's not like a fully
open world game it's not one big giant
map it's actually a bunch of discrete
open areas that are connected by a
subway system soon kind of like explore
this area than run down it into a subway
station and like pick a new destination
there's a little cutscene and it whisks
you and your ass in the darkness area
kind of it yeah it's so it's a little
more like that yeah there's some
definite half-light vibes to like to the
way the city's designed it actually for
me suffers cut from kind of the same
problem as Detroit or Shanghai in the
previous game where the city areas don't
really feel like cities too right yeah
um they're like weirdly tubular like if
you're if you're running around and like
Grand Theft Auto or something you kind
of like see an area you can run over to
it you can kind of go wherever you want
it feels like a natural city ya hear
your options for where you can go are
like very limited so it ends up feeling
like a game level but that's just like
that's just me kind of wanting immersion
because as a playable game space it's
actually really impressive it's really
densely packed with like things to find
hidden areas vents terminals to hack
people interact with way more people now
than there were in the previous game
warmer when were people to talk to and
interact with many of whom give you side
quests now in the previous game they're
really
a handful of side quests in the entire
game so even though as a city it doesn't
feel super believable as a game space it
seems to work really well because
there's a lot to do so I you di are you
jumping from frog den to like diff
emissions that are in like different
parts of the world from there yeah so
there was a story based mission that
occurred within Prague but then
immediately after completing that I went
to a different section of the city which
I guess is yes so technically still in
probably not in that same hub world
where I started right um so that was so
technically in Prague but it looked very
different it was like a bombed-out train
station but then after that like sort of
the final segment that I played was in a
different part of the world entirely it
was in like this odd this slum for
augmented people called golem city that
looked very like Blade Runner II like
dystopian everything was made out of
scrap metal somehow a really eerie gold
lighting throughout so yeah that was
totally separate from the main city and
I just like got on a chopper to get
whisked away to that part of the world
wherever that happens to be so it's
still like a linear first-person total /
third person i'm guessing experience
yeah the narrative and like the the main
campaign is definitely not here how did
the action feel then is it familiar to
human Revolution or so too yeah the
human revolution is it the same sort of
like cover mechanic third person you can
stealth you can actually like did it
feel all that different because like a
lot of people know chata are pointing at
the fact that this seems like the
reception that it seems to be quite like
there is much hype going into this
almost like we kind of it feels like a
known quantity does it play a lot like
the previous game it no it definitely
does I mean certain things have been
improved or fleshed out like for example
the big gameplay hook for Fred and
jensen's that his body has like all
these cybernetic enhancements which
manifests in various ways usually in
terms of like weapons or you know like
hacking abilities or stealth abilities
things like that so there are new new
augments available many of which are
allow you to play non-lethally which in
the previous game most of the augments
seemed to be combat oriented so right I
clearly heard that criticism were like
okay we're gonna try to implement new
augments that really foster these
different play styles and encourage
people to play different ways but yeah
that part of it is still very true the
game very much focuses on allowing you
to play how you want to play and a lot
of the staples of the game
they're like the switching between third
person first person when you go into
cover um the ability to like cloak and
move and like finding those hidden vents
or hacking terminals like all that stuff
plays very similarly to how it did in
the previous game and I guess the Devils
in the detail a lot of this sort of
stuff like so how did it feel to you
over the arrows you were playing that it
was at an enjoyable experience were
there levels that you played through
that you thought hey I wouldn't mind
redoing that as action or stealth or did
it feel like too familiar it was kind of
a mix i mean i think the game still
actually has some rough edges um there
are clearly a lot of really great ideas
and I'm still very optimistic about the
game I will say that the combat I never
quite got a feel for it I never really
had too much fun I feel like the game
really limits your ammo supply and her
energy supply so if you're like going
full loud you trying to kill everybody
you have to be very careful in how you
do it because you could easily run out
of resources right or just get straight
up murdered just use a chainsaw and the
I'm evolved yeah Peter immediately this
is very much not doom and I yeah but in
a way I think that's actually kind of
great like there are so many great there
person shooters out there that if you
want to just go like bang bang shoot E
whatever right you have tons of options
to that what I think this game does
really well is giving you almost more of
like a mass effect style approach to
things where you can socialize your way
through things you can like stealth your
way through things I really prefer those
sexy rating probably uh there's like a
potential love interest in the story
okay maybe maybe not but I I didn't see
any sec there's a shower scene alright
so that that happens get to see all of
ya augmentin yes sexy augments and like
a steamy shower then that was I know
what I'd all guess um no sex scenes that
I saw though but yeah they really
fleshed out the dialogue system which I
i'm a total sucker for like I love
branching dialogue trees like math
Specter fallout so there's a lot more of
that in this game and I feel like you
have more control over those
conversations as a player they needed
before you have more opportunities to
pick dialogue options and direct the way
things are going so I thought that was
really cool so I'm optimistic about
those pillars like the social and the
stealth pillars to me are really
exciting it really fun similar to the
previous game but still really cool cool
I'm kind of curious how you felt about
the the facial animations like I got
problems with Adam Jensen's voice don't
know me because that's a personal
nitpick but looking at the facial
animations and people talk
it looks like really outdated ya know I
I definitely agree they look really
wonky and almost like out of sync and I
kept wondering if like I don't think
that's just like our video like that's
how I remember being when I was playing
the game live like just me and a console
in the TV so I don't know what the deal
is but I agree that it's it's pretty day
so I'm wondering does that sort of that
aspect like manifest itself in other
ways like are you noticing that this
game is pretty sound throughout or based
on just what I'm looking at with the
dialogue stuff it seems like they sort
of picked and choose what to really pay
attention to yeah I noticed that that
maybe is the case with the game at large
i would say that another good example of
that is actually the the aiming which is
another reason i really don't like the
combat that much it's not a bad but I
feel like the aiming was tuned for mouse
and keyboard i was playing on a
controller so it's very 121 so when you
zoom in suddenly like the reticles
really jumpy even if the sensitivity is
way down which i tend to turn the
sensitivity up when i'm playing shooters
on a console but in this case actually
had to turn it down so that i could aim
accurately while aiming down site so i
mean there's still a month before the
game is out i'm certain there will be a
day one patch because that's what
happens with every game so it's entirely
possible some of those edges will be
smooth before the game comes out so i
don't want to like fully condemn it but
i think that what you're hitting on is
accurate i think there are some rough
edges there are things in the game that
look better than other aspects of the
game right look or feel better um so I
mean tons of great ideas and I have a
lot of faith in this team because they
they really seem to know what they're
doing but yeah I mean it wasn't a
flawless demo I didn't come away going
like this was amazing I can't wait I'm a
little more like reluctant to you know
shower with praise but we'll see you
know it's certainly not like trying to
cast aspersions on the dev team but yeah
they're working with a budget and with a
schedule Gordon like some things have to
fall by the wayside yeah this is the
tragedy of triple-a development it's
always like you're managing time and
budget in manpower and just a million
factors and like your ambitions
sometimes are not going to align with
the final product or do the best you can
but yeah I was actually present
pleasantly surprised by how much they
ended up raining it in for the previous
game how much they sort of like it was a
game with rough edges yeah no dash but
it had sort of enough of a concise
vision that
it was I've kept me coming back anyway
that's kind of the story of deus ex as a
whole series though I don't even think
it was just the right ask gaming yeah
every day of sex game I've looked at is
kind of like yeah like there's something
about it that just doesn't feel like
it's not like they didn't get to go the
finish line all the way then everyone
seems to love these aspects of it yeah
difficult franchise to take over as well
definitely is i mean i agree that
there's just something about the
franchise or something about it's sort
of conspiratorial world and the idea of
the augments and the fact that you
really can play combat stealth or
packing or social it really does support
all of these pillars that's pretty
unique i mean not many games can really
pull that off so I can see why for
certain people this franchise is like
just something they will always love you
know warts and all right yeah it's
interesting you say that because there
hasn't been many games which have done
ash bush we have dishonored two coming
up in 2016 we have very similar in that
sort of respect and then also Warren
Spector working on the new system shock
remake as well which probably won't be
up for a little while but yeah kind of
you know although similar self I'm
excited for that to exist i mean the
early trailer the new system shop looks
really great so if they can make the
whole game look and feel that great then
thumbs up you know say go deus ex
mankind divided coming out august
twenty-third scott where can they see or
a preview what's a cold son case all
right it is on gamespot i believe it's
just called exploring mankind divided
open-world social systems and more
relatively boring title but wonder the
same for people like here listen here's
the stuff of the game that we haven't
made able to see yet come check out what
we actually played recently yeah it's
hard to sex off Adam Jensen and a
headline so it shows all that I was
Jensen that voice will shower all events
he has the worst voiceover it's like
it's the Batman problem right it's like
I why you're doing this but it's a bit
it's a bit like you're forcing it so
Hanny yeah that dude sounds like that in
real life though which is like the most
interviews of that guy like his voice is
he actually sounds like this in real
life it's really crazy he's just missing
the supporting like NPCs like sound far
more convincing than the guy who they
have he's just like smoking two packs of
Reds every day
like for its doom stealing we've got
cybernetic lungs it's cool yeah it's
good point you and beauty of the futures
of smoking to future okay let's wrap up
that Scott thank you so much for coming
on absolutely I read appreciate it and
who's in the back there mr jake deckard
get your ass in here tagging in Jake
tagging it in awesome Alan Johnson hey
how's it going let's go good all the
chat having a good old time talking
about how they think it's interesting
that's August is sort of being taken
over by no man's sky and the other games
in there people are sort of not getting
is I haven't heard anyone really talk
about no man's sky recently I can't tell
if you're being sarcastic ganache no I'm
serious kind of with you a little bit
did I think they've done a good job of
not like talking about it right it seems
like they definitely like reeled it in
to not have like all these expectations
placed against it because of hype it's
probably for the better yes but yeah I
mean that games coming out a couple
weeks gone gold real close to the wire
actually I guess yeah like when I got
the release candidate they put their
photograph up right there on his beard
Sean Murray's def beard looking real
gnarly so we are grills what's the date
today today is the fifth phase the 29
1918-19 thing like here so that game
comes out in two weeks think so we don't
have code yet I'm on hot are we down
code yet we don't have code yet how are
you gonna visit every August night that
idea just like yes I'm back at least yes
I weeks for that yeah i'm actually not
gonna be here for the next two weeks i'm
not planning to be sick again I'm going
back to Europe so you and my heart you
gonna be taken over the show yeah should
be fun times yeah but yeah i'm actually
on going on vacation but I'm actually
really happy to be back by the time once
Congress like arriving back on that
Sunday so two days before so she'll be
good times Jake Decker what's up how you
doing doing pretty good huh yeah I'm all
right editing some hot videos right now
yeah working on something really cool
Mass Effect yo when's that going up
friday history of mass effects it's a
long one is like a really long seeing
the script it's a big ol i took the easy
one but in quake Mass Effect's away it's
only three games but it's a lot there's
a lot to it I don't know I mean I don't
know I've played those games so much
that it's like it kind of comes
naturally but I'm still finding out like
all sorts of cool things about the
development of that game like it's
interesting the dedication he
completed what did you do over the
weekend this is dumbest I wide I
originally I was just like I'll just
play a little bit of one capture footage
and I just played through one I was like
well played to just capture a little bit
footage played through to you wait both
of them almost oh my gosh to but I look
for any excuse to play those games it's
like I know you're saying like well
don't spend too much time capturing but
it's like said well I kind of want to
play these again so I'm gonna take you
to complete the first one again think 10
hours or something like really if you
just mainline it yeah did I only did
like a couple of the really necessary
side quests and just did like right just
powered through it on same for to same
to yes I mean tues much more linear in
that sense like it's not not new eyes
much you're not gonna waste as much time
exploring you're just like screw all
your companion missions here all gonna
die and nice work all right uh we're
running here to talk to my mass effect
we're here to talk about the only game
that anyone cares about right now if you
go on any video game website hell if you
go turn your television on if you walk
outside if you walk if you walk out your
window yes right now there are hordes of
teens walking around with their phones
edge not just too much a grown-ass
adults me included the Pokemon goes and
it goes it goes and it goes look let's
let's be honest here right everyone's
covering this game too much it's a
constant source of traffic for us it is
doing all the articles doing loads of
page views the videos are doing load so
I was like we're gonna have to talk
about Pokemon just nothing else to talk
about we have talked about Pokemon go so
at the very least we can have a funny
wrap-up of all the stupidest news
stories that are about Pokemon go it's
alright son ok said ok sorry we go
nitzer ok ok no more down votes Oh guess
that's it so first I've got a couple of
stories here okay and I want to
basically gauge your guys's opinion on
this the first one man quits job in
order to catch all the pokemon ok this
is a coming out of our hot scoops over
at mashable com and this is a gentleman
who worked as a barista somewhere in New
Zealand and he is basically quit his job
so he can Instagram take photographs of
every single Pokemon all to how many is
a
50 in Pokemon go 15 to 50 slots 150 in
total right I'll see there's like groups
of people don't know the slots but yeah
this is just the original because I've
just got 250 zoo bots right now so I'm
pretty cool okay why do you think about
quitting your job to catch all the
pokemon pita bread I mean I'm maybe it's
just what this guy needs to live a happy
fulfilling life I don't know just sick
of making coffees not for me no I
couldn't do it I couldn't do I pardon me
things like strike two months from now
he's gonna be like man two months
reading the hell was I think I think
he's gone now how long does it take to
catch all under 50 catch and evolve
rather do you think it like yeah I do
you think he'll get to the end of the
two feet don't I'm not gonna I need the
regret what calm I'm not gonna doubt his
commitment to his charge okay but once
he reaches it then what I mean I like
the idea that he's going to be fully
committed until he'd reaches it that's a
man it's gonna be late that moment when
Forrest Gump runs all the way to the
west coast right and then gets in he's
like Oh better run back there are
pictures of him here with I don't know
what [ __ ] what is that of some sort
of pony OC is he is he dressed well yeah
yeah he's just taking no he's not
dressed like a she's just hanging out
with this thing then his ass Mittman
isn't is that's true yes beautiful it's
a picture of him at the border power
bank a Christchurch I think this guy
must just love thee it's got four
thousand followers is it a lot no I
don't know he's got a facebook you gonna
hang out with him on facebook go to
facebook.com forward slash tom bleah be
and Zed ple be not sure if that's a
surname where things happen in New
Zealand ok next story that that's their
dares all the pictures look at us look
at a hot Instagram content look at us
dang don't get those views making coffee
hey fair play to him he definitely drop
Pokemon in espresso phone dawg that's
pretty good actually you should probably
comment on this thing ok next one this
is a video I'm not sure if the guys in
the back have this cute up this is uh
I'm gonna call it I'm gonna go ahead and
say it man falls into pond playing
pokemon go yeah this is somebody who was
at twitch streaming their pokemon go
play which I just wanted was a twitch
plays my pokemon go
or something they just made him walk
yeah this is a lot of water but if you
say so it's the same at night I'm just
walking along collecting some pokemon
and then suddenly it goes dark and you
hear the sound of water it's like
zakariya I'm like to the point where it
sounds like his microphone it's just
like totally that there we go nice gone
there you go the obvious mistake there
is that he wasn't playing an AR mode the
right thing could have been I didn't see
in the darkness that's gotta that's
gotta suck jumping I live beside a lake
and literally the whole thing I walk
around us all the time me my partner
dear like probably like three times a
week maybe the whole thing just likes
random groups of people like dropping
lowers just start putting questions in
so they won't know just because they're
so into their phone right right that
could be my twitch stream just go ahead
pushing other people i was on instagram
I'll just do it like i'll make sure i'm
eating a doughnut so it's part of
twitches like eating oh right right
right right yeah it's great social
easily done socially eating a donut
holding i guess your phone and then walk
around how would you push me just like
oh but while talking about league of
legends don't look at me like that's not
the future games conference change okay
next one local businesses dropping lures
how do we feel about this radioshack had
a twenty-five percent off power banks if
you catch a Pokemon nothing's gonna say
British actor you don't like radio shack
no they went bankrupt like two years ago
oh really ninety percent of their stores
they're hanging on by a thread okay well
so they got it yeah that's what you
gotta do there's a there's a cafe right
down the block that's got like a little
chalkboard pokemon on it okay talking
about come here two to 230 we're
dropping lures like crazy like the set
in the other get ten percent off i mean
i think for businesses it's a it's a
real smart move but certain brands or
maybe just types of businesses played
more to that demographic like radio
shack right or coffee or hillary clinton
cuz i guess she's drying Laura stew for
her yeah yet to get solo come to her
stuff Mike and I ubered here and the
uber driver told us all about like
people he's driven around like catch
pokemon like
to the middle of nowhere he told us
about how Hillary Clinton I guess is
dropping lures so she can i mean i don't
know like trying to monetize teens I
guess but like I don't know it seems to
be a good I don't know not a bad way to
get people to go to your rally she's one
of the ashes hats to wear directly write
out some catch pokemon did you see the
UFC guy as a little bit of an aside the
UFC fight wasn't UFC sorry with Bellator
Ithaca was and the fighter who know he
like rolled a ball he kneeled him yeah
and then he like threw he picked out his
gum shield rolled it towards him after
he like basically teak out and and then
like put the cap on when like that oh my
god the most messed up part I stories if
that guy like as literally fractured his
skull open well then he's a spittle
right now yes there's like it'sit's
cyborgs X it was a who's a UFC fighter
now she's one of the head welterweight
women's division fighters and it's her
husband and his there's a picture of him
hospital in the UK and he literally is
like a like it looks like his head just
got like launched it's so bad so this
guy was like literally holding his face
kulbir together and the guy was like
Google patrolling him like ash ketchum
yeah which is you guy who I almost
killed and that's pretty [ __ ] up what
do you think about the mcdonalds thing
have you heard about this so pioneer
editor is like busted open the code and
fan at dash like McDonald's are the
first like Oh sponsored shinning yeah so
all mcdonalds are gonna be I think Jim's
sure it's a logical conclusion I mean
it's that's where the money is yeah no
problem you don't care for all the
players now I mean what I mean people
are going to mcdonalds if they want what
if there's a mamas and papas burger
joint across the road which was a gym I
mean I like oh no we can't you be a gym
anymore we're gonna give it to Ronald
over here I suppose that's true but
would you think like that I think the
ethics in burger selling I think like
the bigger problem though is that all
this walking they're doing is for
nothing now that they just go to make
McDonald said it's good point as long as
you don't have to like eat at McDonald's
or like go like there's no restrictions
like that and like whatever who cares
thumbs in that bad no I eat McDonald's
but I'm saying if you try to drum up any
sort of like is this controversial oh
right that would be the only thing that
could like if you had vibe you get like
a free side up if you bought a hamburger
yeah cuz I'd be buying hamburgers I'm so
excited oh yeah fine last one here set
it end on a real funny one probably
loads no egg get out of this now man
stabbed all playing pokemon go keeps
playing this is a this is this is a
beautiful story and because mostly of
the the lines you can see the yeah hi
very well highlighted there I basically
risked my life he said I have a line
here and mr. Baker of his first name
I'll come up here michael Baker 21 was
catching pokemon characters in Forest
Grove all right one am what I am monday
when i am on a monday nothing ever
happens when he saw another man walking
in the area and approached him
apparently Michael approached the other
man and I saw a guy go I saw him go by
and asked if he was playing pokemon go
he was like wash stab would you say to
me did you call me a Pokemon a thousand
person today I can't take it I guess he
wanted to battle because he came up at
me with a knife Baker told him ah yeah
right after I was stabbed by continue
with my mission to plate pantry for my
mission for chips and beer Baker said so
I me he just got caught on the hand as
it's not bad they but he like they had
to call the cops and he wouldn't he
didn't want to cuz he wanted to catch
pokemon did he get some stitches to sew
it was like kind of bad right i thought
i read he got like eight stitches yeah
but button oh yeah but he wanted to be
the very best i guess i feel like this
is just like a college kid who's like
hey let's set this up like it's his
friend a dress up like fries yeah just
like any good so i won't like the news
for his friend like like like it's like
that tragic tale worry like just stab
him like too much yeah they scream yeah
a new i was pulling this from somewhere
thank you fear you're welcome the ending
of scream just now TV show oh yeah are
you are you okay man
you stabbed me too what does he say
thank you hit me in the stomach yeah did
he ever get the beer and chips though
yeah he did he did oh yeah he'd Libya
and then he went on his merry way and
now he's imagine doing that first of all
and then imagine like like saying okay
to the television interview of you being
that much of a pleb yeah like just being
like yeah I'm gonna own this I love
Pokemon so much I almost [ __ ] died
imagine quitting your job to pick tisha
small speakers it's true imagine falling
into a lake just a handful of the
stories we have on this week's Pokemon
co weekend [ __ ] up story read Joe out
of it yeah I have check back next week
on the lobby to find out which ways
humanity is embarrassing itself through
the medium of Pokemon go ok let's get on
to more pressing news where were these
stories when own ingress was out where
are those tragic English incidents the
english ones are we i was listening to
the podcast this week and Jeff was
talking about how apparently they used
to like people would put up walls like
put up like like de brie so people
couldn't get two different ingress
points like they were like super
territorial around us I'd never even
heard of ingress until I have you heard
of ingress for not until Pokemon goes
right thing yeah it's like I don't know
yeah this loads of geocaches where I
live though I so I geo dudes I wait
Trader Joe's car park is full of goddamn
zoo bots they're like everywhere
[ __ ] anyway let's let's press
on to more pressing news ah Pete bran
hey you review video games yeah when
you're not hunting them off to Mike
Mario's yeah yeah this week you are
reviewing or have reviewed a game called
I am set Sunnah which is a game I was
calling I am satsuma so as Lucy James
apparently do you notice the Satsuma
called something else here satsuma isn't
is a fruit I think it's a large orange
and from right so pumpkin Danny okay
sorry yes I think maybe Mandarin might
be the word that's also used for since
it was I don't know it's something like
anyway you were not reviewing a game
about a small delicious fruit you're in
fact reviewing a game which was just
like well this is square enix's studio
day set up to make Square Enix ass games
right
uh I'm gonna say no ok square enix
doesn't make games like this really
anymore right so they're making
Squaresoft like games right ok classic
JRPGs in the sort of Chrono Trigger yeah
I'm fantasy I'm i dial that back a
little bit because if you think about it
chrono trigger is the first real square
enix game right cuz it was a
collaboration between the best of Final
Fantasy debs and the best of Dragon
Quest owns this is before screenings was
the thing but so maybe in some sense
you're right there's like the progenitor
ok technicality I get away on it yeah so
this is they're making games in that
sort of classic sense in the way that
like lots of their other franchises have
evolved in there is the natural way of
things and so what I would sort of gough
me review what did I get seven thousand
oh seven I 10 I on case why you can get
the review right now video review up as
well on the side on YouTube and what I
got from it is that it's it's quite
derivative of sort of square games that
to its benefit or not in a lot of ways
is to its benefit because the source
material is pretty strong the things
that it's pulling from our great things
to reference and the only time it
becomes an issue is I suppose when those
references as someone who played games
like Chrono Trigger and the other RPGs
that were coming out around that time
you just you recognize it and it just
takes you out of that like the moment of
the game and it's distracting one and
then it sort of it makes you feel
cynical because you're like this is just
a paint-by-numbers kind of things right
it's not totally 121 but there are so
many elements that are like yeah I've
seen this before but at the same time
like it comes together for a game that
is largely really enjoyable and yes
makes me feel nostalgic in a good way as
well as the combat work is it in the
sort of fun classic final fantasy 7
worked Chrono Trigger II it's definitely
it's almost exactly like Chrono Trigger
essentially there are no random
encounters you see enemies on all right
on the field you bump into them everyone
kind of like hops into position you can
avoid them if you want you can avoid
them if you want like if they are
looking one way or another you can sneak
behind them so yeah it's turn based
although you can play in active mode or
wait mode active mode lets the turn
meter keep charging even when you're
making a decision will
lets you take your time and think a
little bit more rather than having to
like make a decision before wasting cool
could you choose to swap can you start
the game on wait mode and go into
honking mode you can swap at any time
okay let's go yeah so you can get used
to it yeah many other cool things is
that characters can combine skills so
they may have one character may have a
heel attack now the one may have like a
whirlwind attack kind of thing and you
can if they're in your party and they
both have those skills equips you can
combine them and like heal your whole
party with one big weirdo other than
just one person and that applies to
offensive stuff as well so there's a lot
of depth to explore in terms of building
your party and fitting out individual
characters and then fitting out a team
with those disparate parts and how they
work together excellent and what type of
like how many characters are we talking
about here I'm guessing you're going out
into the field and meeting people and
visiting them to your party and stuff
yeah I want to say it's like six or
seven okay I don't have an exact number
stop my head right I've doesn't not a
crazy amount right not a super long game
with either know about 20 hours JRPG
anyway I me 20 hours is pretty good
right yeah so that the 20-hour thing is
interesting because it does sort of like
keep the pace up which is good but there
are certain things that feel like
they're worth further examination like a
character who has a really big secret
these kind of reveals it to knees like
let's just keep this between ourselves
you know but but wait there's so much to
talk about like I want to know more I
want to know this and that and it
honestly never really has a resolution
one that's satisfying anyway and they're
even characters like there's a guy with
a scythe who is he's like a direct like
recreation of Magus from chrono triggers
guy with a scythe who's kind of you know
he's evil but he doesn't really get the
same development his magnets like you
don't get to to understand him in his
motivations he kind of just appears and
is like the perfunctory bad guy right
but you know a lot of the characters
what makes the story interesting is the
characters themselves bringing emotional
baggage to the table they don't
necessarily develop it which is too bad
but they all have something about them
that is like kind of tragic makes you
sympathize with them a little bit
questions coming from the chat and jigna
didn't start asking at what consoles as
for would you play it on I put it on
PlayStation 4 it's also coming to steam
in North America and Europe cool Japan
got a Vita version we are not getting
that oh really yeah okay unfortunately
that's a shame but you can play a virum
at play if you want
god I wonder why that seems it seems
like cuz i became that i actually would
pick up on it's made in unity check a
box yeah raw [ __ ] that's already done
they just didn't I don't know that's
bizarre it is strange like why they
would just omit that opportunity to make
money it makes me worried that Sony
aren't even pushing I mean it's square
enix as well you think that would be
something they'd be like look well sort
you out just like put this ad on the
video heads it makes me think that Sony
don't give a [ __ ] anymore basically when
I see things about oh I don't know sorry
Jake we go say oh I was wondering which
boy sorry would you think of the
presentation though cuz I came by your
desk and you were playing and I was like
oh it looks beautiful you're like yeah
like you didn't seem too excited and
then I was like all right well I thought
it looks beautiful and I started editing
the review and I noticed that the
environments look really similar yeah
like they're not 99 percent of the
environments are winterland right right
snowy forest snowy town snowy fields
occasionally you go into these sort of I
don't even like maybe it's another
dimension it's just some sort of weird
place that's dark and you can't really
see much and they're floating things you
assume the rules of nature don't apply
yeah um like I actually really like the
art and there are some scenes where the
lighting and the composition like
framing the scene work really well
together and I think okay someone behind
this took the time to make sure that
this was a special moment but there are
a lot a lot of things that do just look
kind of bland rhyme unfortunately but
but by and large I think maybe I came
around after I played the game some more
and I saw more of those things that were
impressive so I think it's a decent
looking game especially one that like
it's a 3d game that's trying to mimic
what a 2-d game used to do and I think
it does that pretty well yeah cool I
today sure I forget I just remember
embargoes today yeah I'm curious like
how do you feel about this game because
I know that you like Japanese RPGs is
this something that's been on your radar
are you interested it has been on my
radar it because I thought it looked
beautiful to be honest um but then after
editing the review I'm not quite as
excited as I was before I think just
because what I did edit it looked a lot
of like the same stuff and like even a
dungeon stuff that you did give me just
felt very like it just felt kind of out
of place but i mean i'll still probably
give it a try and i think and everyone's
been talking about how great the music
is too i don't know you thought that but
that's kind of something i do wanna
that's it yeah that's a weird thing for
me I did really like the music it's all
piano right which over time it kind of
drags you down a little bit like I love
listening to piano arrangements of
classic game soundtracks is a wonderful
instrument but for an entire game to be
just one instrument is a bit much the
thing that really got me was some of the
songs are so clearly riffing on a
trigger music really where it's like the
same chord progression just a different
tempo or done from your structure yeah
and like that's this kind of thing where
i'm like this is [ __ ] lazy right i
cannot respect i can say yeah it's
beautiful but i don't respect that song
that's like the artistry behind it's a
difficult line to sort of walk right to
be like referential to the past what I'm
having it up to my you think I kind of
crosses over it's a little bit to drill
absolute absolute lee yeah i mean this
this game is littered with things that
if you've been playing Japanese RPGs for
years you will say okay that is that is
frog from Chrono Trigger that is our on
from final fantasy 10 right this is the
plot from final fantasy 10 that's
printed triggers battle system the
random events from the saga frontier
games at hacker during battle it all
these things just you know kind of
coalesce into a thing that that's just
super referential yeah the few times it
does stand out though I did feel like
the game has an identity of its own I
would just love to see them take all
this knowledge and expertise making it a
classic RPG mmm but doing something
totally original with it not just trying
to say hey guys fans I know what you
like you've been asking for a few years
here it is like stop complaining like
okay but you have to take the next step
yeah it can't just be that yeah I don't
think we're gonna be talking about this
game in 20 years right we talk about
chrono trigger now but a fun game to
play yes I think people should play it I
mean I seven is an endorsement in my
book it's good out of 10 not really 7
out of 10 and that's the way I like to
think about it yeah yeah good stuff out
today on a Playstation 4 I guess no Vita
version for us right yes the steam
version should be out today ok steam as
well yeah pick it out there if you want
at 3999 as I checks might be a bit
cheaper on steam on launch day that
sometimes happens go check it out thank
you so much Peter yeah appreciate it I
think Jimmy thang is going to be in the
wings you've got them in in a second and
to talk about hot hardware and what are
you playing at the moment though Jake
are you enjoying its it's as weird
dead zone at the moment actually I
started playing blood and wine based on
your oh yeah a recommendation sweet yeah
it's really good i want to go back and
play it more but i think stop replaying
or pg's all the time I know especially
really long ones that are taking the
hours before you go why do you why are
you playing at the moment are you um oh
I mean mostly Mass Effect I'd say paying
attention completed the third one yet
yeah are you doing here nothing is great
he's got it does a good like four
paragraphs of the script which is but
been getting a mass effect 3 um but yeah
that's it looking forward to no man's
sky though cool yeah play that a lot
tick-tock it's coming soon thanks so
much man I'm playing right now what are
you playing right now Peter I also care
about you no you don't the king of
fighters 14 demo all right it did how is
it it's her 8 has that 2.5 d doing
that's fine it's fine yeah timing the
animations the controllers all feel
right cool no complaints they did it I'm
looking forward to that game good that's
interesting because a lot of people were
kind of like oh I want to play out at
first the way the characters were
rendered looked like a UH pres ps2 game
they've fixed some of that good stuff
yeah and drama to release day
predictions asks man on it 1998 god was
that person born are they 2020 18 years
old there you go Mass Effect Andromeda
next year this on my next year the
future I'm tongue on the future sometime
in the future Jimmy thang what are you
playing at the moment a lot of overwatch
oh really yeah have you been enjoying
competitive mode I have been yes i'm
currently ranked 55 i think which is a
in the world wow you should quit this
video for as much as i want see nope the
best players so I'm like terrified to go
back now because I haven't played since
e3 okay and I'm really worried that I'm
[ __ ] but like everyone else don't worry
good i'll carry you appreciated i have
you played much with anna yet uh just
very briefly i think like once is she in
like the public because i know you could
like opt in to her she's in the pto I
don't know if she's only if they've
actually passed her into the actual
right so is out like test realms where
you can only play against other people
who've also opted to have her that's
really weird does I mean you're getting
into maps were basically everyone is
picking her then pretty much more like
uh you know zenyatta who's like buffed
and things like the right okay didn't
they set up a new mode where they only
allow one character that's the new
competitive Oh rolled into battle yes
it's the thing they said they'd never do
Never Say Never yeah that's interesting
i think i have not more time who do I
have kaplan on record saying that they
did he say never did he say well so
you're not locked into the character
though no you're not but then but the
other things one explicitly said like
pretty sure i need to go back and have a
look at that one if it was it was either
then or was back at Gamescom when we
interviewed him there um well yeah cuz
that was one of the things was that they
were we were when we played at a
blizzcon everyone was there was like
three it was when bastion had the shield
sure and there was like everyone would
load up as bastions that it was like a
nightmare because back then Bastion had
a shield as well which meant you could
put a turbulent herbicide Bastion and
they'd both be shielded so you could
just like Rang copy I am it was after
that we asked and he said i get if the
room didn't maybe he said like we've no
plans to do that i don't know but we
shall see ok let's say let's not talk
about overwatch let's talk a bash
hardware Jimmy thang you're here a new
graphics card has come at it had the
1060 richa is 10 lower than the last
perfect card so that makes that leads me
to believe that this is perhaps some
sort of budget card in that same family
it's it's in the same family uses the
Pascal microarchitecture um budget not
so much i would say mid-range okay it's
starting at two hundred fifty dollars it
the card that i reviewed is the
essentially the reference model the
founders edition which is three hundred
dollars right and yeah it's it's
basically the card that a lot of people
will get because it offers really good
performance for 1080p and it's not
outrageously expensive right yeah 250
seems like pretty like you standard i
think it's like it's actually like one
of the most popular price ranges right
it's yeah it's weird have that consumer
purchasing sort of stuff goes where they
they know where four people say me
nice area because if you spend you know
too much money if you spend over five
hundred dollars you get diminishing
returns yes it's for the people who have
you know disposable income out there and
then if you spend too much it's like
later on down the road you're gonna have
to upgrade or whatever too or you'll
want to but this is sort of in that
sweet spot so we talks a lot last time
about the sort of the pros and cons of
going for the 1080 over the 1070 and
it's kind of impossible talk about these
cards we're not referring to the rest of
the members of their family so what what
is it about the 1060 like how how much
close is it to the 1070 how much worth
is it just like throwing you that extra
cup like a sheep you have it to get the
1070 sure so the 1070 is let's see I
wrote this down it is twenty-three
percent faster okay then the 1060 but
it's also thirty-three percent more
expensive right so the 10 sec 1060 is
actually a better deal if you are like
most people game at 1080p um you know if
you want a game at that resolution then
I'd say go with the 1060 the 1070 is
more for like 1440p or if you want to
like sort of dabble in 4k right what
about where does virtual reality coming
to this to anything because I'm you know
again I'm kind of super lame any when it
comes to this like I built my own pc
again my months ago but I don't keep on
top of it all the time but it seems to
be that people are saying you should get
that extra bit of power if you're going
to try and run virtual or multiple
monitors I guess which is well yeah I
mean I think I've said this before but
VR is very graphically demanding you
need to have it's basically running to
you know 1080p panels in a way right uh
in in each eye and then you have to
maintain a really high refresh rate or
frame rate of them like 90 frames per
second or a liar consistently if it
drops it kind of makes mix it can make
you motion sick yeah so it's really
important to have a high resolution and
high refresh rate the 1064 two hundred
fifty dollars can do that and also AMD
also release the car not that long ago
the RX for 80 which starts at two
hundred dollars and I'm actually going
to put together a VR build like a really
affordable VR build I'm gonna try to get
it below eight hundred dollars that can
do that as well cool yeah I saw asus was
telling one of their raag systems built
for VR for like seven hundred dollars
six hundred olives really
yeah super well it may have been like a
deal but their kids certain the
discussions list on the cost of a vibe
but I think I see the discussion
changing around VR pretty soon like in
the near future you know where it's this
cost prohibitive thing and that's going
to kind of go away and people are just
gonna be buying pcs it like yeah like
this is VR just works on my pc right I
didn't buy it for VR like it's really
powerful enough out of the gate yeah i'm
looking forward to that because I think
that's the sort of thing that's gonna
make devs more inspired to actually
treat VR like a worthwhile pursuit yeah
right that is if it's not like it's not
like to get a VR pc it's like this
magical sort of acquirement like if you
have a like a high-end gaming PC that's
gonna be able to do no totally yeah but
for a lot of people I think they're
there maybe they're not gaming like like
a hardcore gamer yeah and they're just
like what everybody's be our thing what
do I need to do it oh that's too
expensive like it's it's that type of
thing where you're like you you budget
for the 600 or 800 daughter thing and
then you're like oh but i also like
needs to upgrade my grabbers got like i
used to get that a lot when i worked in
retail which is like people will come in
I'm wanted to buy a game for their kid
and then you'd be like oh but your
system requirements are this and they'd
be like ah there's no point and I'll
just get them this other thing like or
you know they wanted to get them the new
console and then realize that all the
games cost way more because they're all
new games like there's always that once
you add that like extra cost on to
people that it sometimes becomes that
extra barrier that just kind of stops
them from doing it right yeah yeah so I
should be producing I guess and yeah I
mean it seems like a pretty good one I'm
guessing like what was the game which
started to struggle out for you was it
because I I see when your benchmarks
there's all like the good touchstones of
you know those crazy Eastern European
first-person shooters by rashah can
finish all that sort of stuff so games
like like you know BioShock Infinite
shadow of mordor those games are sort of
what i would consider like mid-range
graphics kind of games like they're
going to look pretty they're gonna run
pretty well or well optimized games that
will really push your system include
metro last light right um and like rise
of the Tomb Raider yeah I mean like the
witch or to some extent to a lesser
extent but yeah i'll test out a bunch of
different games so like bioshock
infinite will be like here's a game
that's not super easy to run
like it will run on like you know it
should be a matter it game and then like
metro last light will be like here's the
final test like where I can do this one
that he can do this resolution have you
thought about introducing doom into that
I'm seeing a lot of people talking about
how I didn't vote yeah the Pelican I
think Peter was complaining that my
reviews too long so I want to add more
benchmarks early look at you in the
future is there such a thing as too long
for harder of you I feel like the people
who were my reviews I reviews are really
they are hard it was like 4,000 workers
so it's like reviewers like how come you
don't have more benchmarks and I'm like
this is already ridiculously and then
not only that I have to go and like test
like five other cards like run all those
benchmarks to of course and then like a
lot of people don't know like I have
sometimes I have like three days or
whatever like a week to view these and I
don't have time to like burning
benchmarks like takes time oh yeah it
seems simple right just go to the MIT
for some games just go to the menu hit
benchmark but it's a pain in the ass
yeah and I'm like yeah I'm also doing
like experiential benchmarks where I'm
like I'm literally playing the games and
like running fraps and recording average
right yeah it's like that right it's
very it's very time intensive and last
question on 1060 SLI yes so s lie is not
supported wise a very this is you know
it's a bit of a shame for a cry because
anything call you could run an SLI set
up for 500 quid like that'd be pretty
cool yeah so um so in general I wouldn't
recommend most people go out and buy SLI
system you know I generally recommend
people buy one powerful graphics card
over to because with SLI you have
performance scaling issues like some
games don't even support sli some games
will run worse on that slide right she's
a sins creed one of the assassins creed
ones had that issue having said that
though you know some games do support
and it's nice to have the option you
know especially later on down the road
like let's say year or two from now in
10 sixties really cheap you'd want to
like just get another one for cheap and
then at an SLI get like near double
performance in some games but with 1060
yeah it doesn't support sli which was
very surprising to me I asked nvidia why
and they said that it's not very common
in mid-range GPUs and that they're sort
of relegating that to the 1070 and 1080
changes where it's more common do you
think that we're
patronis a past SLI but do you think sli
will sort of continue to exist or have
we reached the sort of you know we've
we've jumped up so good at your always
getting to get our if there was going to
movies always many more power people
always going to want better graphics I
think next-generation consoles are
always gonna come kind of thing um so
it's yeah I think we're always gonna
want more power I was actually
interviewing tips we need the other week
hmm and I asked him like how many
teraflops would we need to reach
photorealistic graphics and he said he
thinks around 40 teraflops and 40 40
okay tariff the 1080 is like nine
teraflops and the new xbox is like six
right so like sort of gives you the idea
like we're far away from like achieving
realistic graphics there you go a lot
more work to be done Jimmy thank thank
you so much for coming in at 10 secs
your full review is on gamespot com if
you want all those hot [ __ ] [ __ ] stats
head over to the side and I check it out
now all right we're pretty much done no
no for the show what do you what are you
playing for the rest of your week Peter
Brown the next Jamie you can stick
around you're good you can stick right
I'm gonna be tackling head Lander the
new double oh qoodles when collaboration
yes next week yeah it's like a weird 70s
theme kind of mix and match robot thing
and Troy be Nia item-based exploration
game okay to describe its wake a seer
massive roid um after that ABS you I
believe oh cool next week yes I made a
cool booth 83 yeah you can add fish fake
fish and then any blues no Saudi maybe
no man's sky whenever we get ok I'll see
about that Jimmy you gonna keep playing
some Oh hot ones just plain over what so
I'm trying to guess what he was trying
to get out of here so yeah we get to the
54th I guess rest players are we done
harvest I stopped playing overwatch I
was battlefield one like took up so much
of my I wasn't expecting to really like
that guy like about 43 I enjoyed bout
fear for I was kind of like dawn on I
really love 9040 to Vietnam and that
company was great but I thought I'd give
it a go the closed alpha
I got I played 16 hours of that one map
over and over again I really like about
if we want a lot I was so surprised so
I'm looking forward to seeing where that
yeah I really I want them to get that
open that alpha head to people because I
think it's gonna be one of those games
are like once people play are gonna be
like oh this is actually like different
are they are the guns like will were one
gun there so shitty like they're not
tonight they're not as shitty as they
should because they're clearly like the
end of World War one okay creeping into
world war two guns but it's so much fun
to like because like i was playing
overwatch right so you got like
Widowmaker and you've got like like tick
tick click boom and you basically a head
shot somebody from across the map and in
this that are running across the way so
this bullet drag and it drops the
bullets drop and they lower in speed and
effectiveness and then you also have to
like lead the shot for the time it takes
to get there so when you and then when
you hit them you don't kill them unless
you get a headshot so when if you kill
somebody from like the 300 yards but i
think it is like you're you're gone it's
on blue and yeah like even even like the
shotgun in it is pretty powerful but
like even machine guns and stuff they're
there there's a lot of recoil and
they're they're kind of you don't it
doesn't feel powerful so I kind of hot
like I sucked so bad for the first like
four hours and I basically just have to
like rethink how you play these guns you
can't just like run along and like aim
down sights and shoot it's like if
you're using the machine go and you have
to be like in a prone position or you
know if using sniper rifle make sure
beside a piece of cover t you can put
your rifle up on and and they're like
finding your role and like realizing
again that it's not about kills it's
about finding objectives I was gonna say
love but it's been yeah the one story /
01 the board that everyone came together
and there is that like the coolest thing
I think about the whole thing and I do
feel like I'm hoping the crowd better
this game out of it but the one thing
that I kept loving every single time is
I got the start of the map you basically
this one map anyway you're fighting over
this one like village right and on one
side it's basically like the start of no
man's land behind it's just like
trenches and mud for maza miles and then
this side it's kind of like decent
countryside in there they're fighting
over this one village let's call these
objective points in our like windmills
and tans and all this sort of stop and
by the end for the map it's just [ __ ]
level like it's just slop and mud and
the buildings are falling apart like no
even like a oh you hit the thing to
trigger the level to explode it's just
like constant battering tanks hitting
into walls like bombs going off and by
the end it's just it's it's amazing
because it totally changes the tactics
like you're holed up in a house and like
half the third floor gets blown off and
then something you're like running
around on top of the roof or like it's
amazing like by the end of the level
it's just the whole places it's looks
completely different tactically it's
totally different because then it's hard
to snipe when there's no buildings to
hiding or like there's no walls the hide
behind and there's a really frantic
feeling and then the strings they're
like music they use the violin music is
so evocative and then what class is that
look at the violin class yeah string
class no don't you could play pokemon go
and now we're gonna walk in the
background race yeah something like this
like a spiky helmet on yeah there you go
sorry gotta done yay ah all right that's
the show this week I will be back next
thing I won't be here Mike mahadji will
be hosting with all your favorite
gamespot heroes and here on the lobby
thank you so much for hanging out as
ever really appreciate it and make sure
you hit the subscribe button if you're
on YouTube from GameSpot we will see you
bright and early next week again I thank
you so much for everything in the back
of course putting this whole thing
together jean-luc site key mirka sh air
Tay Richard Leon camera good man feeling
strong nope use it evo all last week I'm
surprised you're even in this week
managed takes and got on time off those
fighting game eSports all right red here
play pokemon go we'll talk about weird
headlines next week
you